Hausa Gomer as many welcome to skate
three this game was actually kind of old
but I heard it was hilarious
so I thought we were just gonna go
freestyling and see what's gonna happen
I don't know how you're ready for a bob
bob is excited look at him so happy
Bob Bob let's find some cool places to
skate I said what what this game is all
about I guess and making out with
railings let's follow this guy are you
doing great sir why now we're doing good
I call this one I don't even know whoa
thank you pretty badass where are we
going Bob I push [ __ ] like like he's
doing now I can do it any other way I
know a lot of people like it kids push
[ __ ] unsubscribe out pretty cool
nevermind odom skills i bob let's see if
you can jump some higher jumps or
whatever go yeah you did it Bob alright
let's step it up a notch gah Bob [ __ ]
crazy man come on I'm flying here top
flight shut up Bob you're too fat to fly
alright let's see if we can jump the
shark
oh I actually did it holy [ __ ]
I became a butterfly I became a
butterfly
whoo I grind the shark oh ah
[Music]
what does it [ __ ] say before he dies
Yolo Oh Bob you're not in the water you
can't swim
I'm doing this game a lot I hope your
brothers are digging it - what
skateboard you can't just leave me like
that I have the foss that father is
strong with this fat man oh he's just
sunbathing come on Bob
you can fly I believe in your dreams
[Music]
break it down Tim go it's area looks
pretty cool oh [ __ ] Bob what are you
doing there I don't care this is scary
feel no fear Bob is queer just hang in
there Bob he's like I can see my
genitals I don't care take me
[Laughter]
they live in your dreams and anything
can happen
oh I feel so bad for this guy seriously
I did it
holy [ __ ] high five res fab 5 you go
skateboard by the way I have a penny
board laying around here somewhere
it's a good feeling just being on the
board I love it if I want to go
somewhere quick but I can to make
awesome tricks like Bob though you're
not a frog Bob such a dirt man here we
go
Eric Conn's well that was anticlimactic
what the [ __ ] are you doing man okay
here we go
[Applause]
not really what I hope for but hey I'll
take it okay I'm fabulous oh yeah oh
come on Bob show those [ __ ] whoa whoa
yeah baby
yes here we go
yeah I didn't even do it if Bobby's very
upset get out of my way parking thing I
want to try something different that's
running fast man perfect
come on come on Bob you can slam dunk
yeah he's too bad
come on oh here we go
whoa this is a skateboarding game in
case you don't know this is a
skateboarding game
and not a single [ __ ] was given oh I'm
having way too much fun with this
[ __ ] game
nailed it come on yeah okay this should
be pretty interesting yeah it's pretty
cool shake no it's okay take your time
Bob really great
I won't deaf [ __ ] every time
all right Prez I'm gonna have to end
after soda here I hope you boys enjoy
watching leave a like if you did I'd
really appreciate it and let me know if
you want more hits the sky comer
birthday I see you breasts as always in
the next one
stay awesome love you bread
hahaha
oh god this guy what them oh yeah
voila
[Laughter]